sieht so aus so von wegen
mein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zahlen 9 wie die tage mal so durch
instagram gestöbert und hab dann so ein
profil gefunden links have drohen auf
deutsch übersetzt der profil name also
so was in die richtung wie das sind
sachen die ich gemalt habe und dann als
profilbild haben sie dieses hier sehr
sehr kreativ okay was soll ich sagen ich
mein profil bild besteht aus einem
smiley aus sondern der trade it in der
bio hat dieser account drinstehen mein
name ist dominik joint instagram tv
amazing and my brother herles ausländer
contributing der texte fotos also wird
dieses profil geführt von drei personen
einmal ein kleiner junge namens tom
seinen noch kleinerer bruder namens l
und der vater der die fotos machen
übrigens hier leute könnt ihr ab morgen
morgen morgen morgen 16 uhr luca bino
shop.de aber ich komme jetzt mal auf den
punkt dieser instagram account besteht
daraus dass die beiden kleinen brüder r
und tom bilder malen mit einem bleistift
auf ein blatt papier und der vater
photoshop das in die echte welt und ich
denke wir alle wissen wie gut kleine
kinder malen könnte das hier ist das
erste gemalte bild von einem der kleinen
kinder und zwar soll das wohl irgendwie
mehr sein der hat seinen mund auf und
berühmtheit so ein bisschen nach den
einnahmen oben den annahmen irgendwie
unten und das was der vater jetzt macht
es quasi in diesen bären ins web zu
photoshop und zwar sieht das ganze dann
so aus so beschreibt hier hat einer
seiner söhne den charts tower aus london
bezeichnet ich zeige euch ein echtes
bild von dem schattauer da der bei den
sohn allerdings so ausgeht hat sich der
vater gedacht ihr euch photoshop den mal
in london
21 das ganze dann so aus ziemlich gerade
super dass ihr sohn irgendein frosch
sein wird die gelben füßen und im
relativ kleinen kopf
ein paar sekunden später sorry bei mir
wird gerade eine couch geliefert also
deswegen schaltet bisschen happy waren
stehen geblieben bei diesem frosch hier
und zwar sieht der in real life so aus
plate mit den beinen find ich das hier
ist nicht die sonne sondern ein löwe
kann man nicht erkennen ich auch nicht
jeden fall zieht der löwe photoshop dann
so aus mit dieser fresse missgeburten
ich glaub mir so einen löwen der
bildband begegnen würdest wer mir
scheißegal das hier soll ein zebra sein
was der kleine junge da gemalt hat
allerdings das gesicht hat irgendwie
schief und das hat der vater auch bei
dem photoshop bild bedacht und das ganze
so dargestellt
ich weiß ja nie was dazu sagen soll die
toppartie den schrott eingeflogen
was meiner bestimmen einen kopf von
leben her dass hier irgend eine mischung
aus einer rakete im flugzeug und dem
vogel und der vater das ganze in
photoshop dann so dargestellt
damit würde ich definitiv nicht fliegen
wollen
haltet euch fest freunde jetzt kommt ein
elefant mit ultra fetten bringen so
sieht er nicht aus
ich bleibe die sachen die ganze zeit
hier links sein ich glaube ich bin das
jetzt mal recht sein damit es ein
bisschen abwechslung ist was das hier
ist weiß ich nicht
irgendwie soll das wohl scharf
darstellen ich finde es sich überhaupt
nicht aus wirtschaft sondern eher wie so
ein monster von monster age
der vater das ganze land gezeichnet und
zwar so sieht so aus so von wegen das
jetzt irgendwie die mischung aus einem
schwanen und nimmer schneemann der indie
gemacht wurde deswegen hat der vater das
dann halt irgendwie so dargestellt also
eine schwan schneemann mischung im eis
und halb verkrüppelt läuft ich gebe
jetzt zehn sekunden zeit um in die
kommentare zu schreiben was das hier ist
es in die kommentare
jetzt zehn sekunden 43 21
eine giraffe ich komme ja echt nicht
darauf klar das was ihr vom video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wird das getan hat las man
fetten like da und bei honda muss ich
euch mein handy werde ich nicht machen
dann gesehen dass wir die tage ein video
hochgeladen hat wird ja immer gesagt
dass ich liebe mein agent so sehr als
dankeschön verlost 40 millionen iphones
und 400 millionen playstation 4 und ich
denke mir nur so spende dein geld
vielleicht anstatt uns ganzen konsum
versierten menschen noch mehr luxus
güter zu geben also es ist wie ich die
machen sowas alles vorgesorgt
es ist bald schon weihnachten und ich
weiß gar nicht wie soll ich das gerade
sage ich habe hunger
ich bin ich weg